[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for my first official
true crime video some of you might not
know this but i have somewhat of an
obsession with these kind of real life
stories
ever since i was a kid i started getting
invested into high profile cases that
would make headlines around the country
now i am sure most of you might know me
as a game of thrones and a song of ice
and fire fan but i might be an even
bigger fan of these real life stories
i think i spend more time watching these
documentaries than i do
almost anything else so i decided i
wanted to start discussing these cases
with everyone else who may be interested
in them just like me
this is why i started my channel after
all so i could talk about whatever is on
my mind
lately i have become reinvested in the
scott and lacey peterson case
the main suspect was arrested convicted
and even condemned
he has been living on death row ever
since his conviction but in a shocking
turn of events
that has now been reversed as of right
now he is no longer on death row
and some even believe he should have
never been there at all
now i actually think he is guilty myself
but if i'm honest
i don't think he should have been
convicted based on the evidence they had
i think the prosecutors had a very weak
case but at the end of the day i
do think he is right where he belongs if
you haven't heard of scott and lacey
peterson then you might be a little lost
right now
scott and lacey met each other during
their college years when they were
working at a diner together
according to scott lacey wrote down her
number for him to have but he kind of
thought it was a joke so he threw it
away
after a second attempt scott and lacey
did speak
and eventually began dating each other
based on everything i've read
scott seemed like he was one of those
blue blood high society rich kids
he was good looking he spent a lot of
time on the golf course
and he was in the wine and cigar club
lacey on the other hand was a sweetheart
she was gorgeous smart funny and all
those things you want to find in a
girlfriend
after being together for several years
everything seemed to be going very well
they got married they got a house
together and their life was only just
beginning
so the next logical step is to have a
child right around
the beginning of 2002 lacey did become
pregnant with their son
who they would name conor as far as lacy
knew
this was about to be the beginning of a
wonderful life but something happened on
christmas eve of 2002 that changed
everything
with only a few weeks left before lacey
gave birth to their son
she goes missing now let's see what
scott said happened on the day she
disappeared
on december 24th christmas eve of 2002
scott says he wakes up at 8 am that day
according to what he said
lacey woke up before him he said she was
eating cereal when he got out of bed
so he ends up grabbing himself a bowl of
cereal as well
while they're sitting there eating they
started watching her favorite show
martha stewart
around 9 or 10 in the morning lacey was
also cleaning up around the house
mopping the floor before she ended up
walking the dog
scott says it was too cold to go golfing
so he decided to go fishing
instead for some reason he said it was
too cold to stand on a golf course but
it wasn't too cold to go fishing in the
san francisco bay
one of scott's neighbors saw him loading
umbrellas in his truck somewhere around
9
30. so scott gets ready for the day and
he leaves for the warehouse where his
brand new boat is at which is about
three miles away from their house
for whatever reason scott was keeping
his boat at the warehouse where he
worked out of as some sort of fertilizer
salesman
after scott does arrive at the warehouse
he goes on to his computer
sometime between 10 30 and 11 am while
he's there
he also makes some of his own homemade
anchors out of concrete mix for when he
goes fishing
later he will say that he only made one
anchor but there might be some evidence
that shows he made more than one
but i will get back to that later we're
not exactly sure how long this takes him
but afterwards
he hooks up his boat to his truck and
then he leaves it takes him about one
and a half hours to get to the berkeley
marina and the san francisco
bay while scott was still at the
warehouse his neighbor caring service
finds the peterson dog outside their
home around 10 18 a.m that day
we know that scott was definitely gone
at that time because she doesn't see his
car there
now if you remember scott said lacey was
gonna walk their dog that morning
so it seemed a bit odd when their
neighbor found their dog walking around
in the yard by itself
with its leash still on so the neighbor
karen
locks their dog up in their backyard
then she leaves
we know that scott was definitely at the
berkeley marina at 12 54 pm that day
because he has a receipt from when he
arrived at the marina
scott said he was only out on the water
from about one to two pm that day
afterwards when scott leaves he calls
lacey at home
and he calls her on her cell phone by 2
15 pm
scott drops off the boat at his
warehouse around 4 30.
and when scott gets home he says the dog
was in the backyard by itself on its
leash
and their door was unlocked the very
first thing he does when he gets inside
the house is he immediately throws his
wet clothes in the washer then he gets a
shower
he says he doesn't call lacy's mom until
after this call is around 5
17 p.m scott tells lacey's mom the car
and the dog are here but lacey isn't
obviously lacey's mom says she hasn't
seen her or heard from her either
this is when lacey's stepfather calls
911 around 5 47 pm
shortly after this is when the cops meet
lacey's parents in the east laloma park
around 6 pm
this is apparently where lacy like to
walk their dog
but unfortunately they don't find her
there so
the cops want to search scott and lacy's
house next when they get there they find
that there's no signs of forced entry
nothing seemed to be out of the ordinary
there was no evidence of a struggle
so it looked like if something did
happen to lacey it did not happen inside
of their house
so from around 6 20 pm to 1 19 am
the cops searched their house in scott's
warehouse the very first
night while they were searching the
house one of the investigators
interviewed scott down at this station
scott says they woke up that morning and
they were watching lacy's favorite show
martha stewart was making cookies or
something with lemon meringue
the investigators did later fact check
this and scott was right
that's exactly what martha stewart was
making on that episode
the investigator also asked scott if
they were having any issues with their
marriage
marriage problems
what he does fail to admit is that he
has been cheating on lacey for the last
several months
he obviously wasn't very happy otherwise
he would not be looking for love and
affection outside of the marriage
but that alone does not automatically
mean scott did something to his wife
scott said the cops were looking at him
as a suspect that first night
and this is normal with these kind of
investigations they usually start from
the inside then they work their way out
now when they were in the driveway
searching scott and lacy's house he
heard one of the cops say over the radio
the husband is suspicious when the
detective
met with scott the following day on
christmas he found it odd that scott did
not seem
interested in the investigation he
wasn't asking any questions
about what they were up to in terms of
finding laci
or solving the case scott was also asked
on christmas eve if he would take a lie
detector test to eliminate himself as a
suspect
he originally said yes but later he
declines now obviously the detective
says this makes him look even more
suspicious
scott's dad told him not to do it so
that's what he did
nothing in the following days aleci's
disappearance
the response from their community was
overwhelming everyone was out looking
for lacey
they actually ran out of flyers and maps
there were volunteers out searching on
foot
horseback and even by boat there were
massive
searches underway immediately the
investigators also had divers searching
the san francisco bay for lacey's body
it says they did dozens of searches in
the bay
obviously they were desperately trying
to find lacey
they were even using sonar technology to
search under the water but they had no
luck
so after a few days the police end up
coming back to the petersen house to
search it again
the detective said they wanted to search
the house again because they wanted to
monitor scott's behavior and demeanor
scott did not allow them to search the
house the second time they executed the
search warrant anyway
the investigator said if scott has
nothing to hide then he should let them
search the house
during the search they found scott's
behavior to be odd
because he seemed more concerned about
his house and cars than he did his
missing wife
for example when one of the cops sat
down a glass of water
scott ran over and made sure the glass
was sitting on a coaster
then when another one of the cops opened
up his car door
scott made sure to stick a glove in
front of the door so it did not scratch
the car sitting next to it
the investigators removed several items
out of scott's house to search for any
traces of evidence related to lacy's
disappearance
they also took both of the cars and
their computers from the house to search
for evidence
based on what i have seen they did not
find anything
in scott and laci's house nor did they
find anything at scott's warehouse
except for one of lacey's hairs that
were found inside of an old pair of
pliers
we later find out that the cops removed
over a hundred different bags of
evidence from scott's house
and the warehouse but after all that was
done the investigators
basically found no worthy evidence to
show during the trial
they did however find something
interesting at the warehouse
as i was saying before they found dry
cement mix all over the floor
showing that scott had made his own
anchors scott said he had only made one
but they said it appeared as if he had
made four when they asked him what he
did with the rest of the cement mix
he said he dumped it out near the
driveway at his house to fill in a hole
in the ground
later we do see a photo that appears to
show some cement mix near scott's
driveway however when that was tested
it was shown to be a different type of
cement mix that was found in the
warehouse
so if that's the case then where did the
rest go
my guess is he made several anchors most
likely to weigh down a body
at this time almost everyone was getting
upset with how scott was reacting to his
wife's disappearance
he was acting as if he did not care
scott's reaction
and his demeanor meant a lot to the
public one of the big issues when having
a case covered by this amount of media
outlets is how the real evidence can
sometimes get lost
these different news organizations have
to feed the beast
so they will begin to report on anything
and everything they can
now regardless of how scott was acting
lacy's family was initially
on his side at the beginning they
honestly did believe he was innocent
every one of their friends thought they
were great together scott's dad said
scott never looked happier than when he
was with lacey one of scott's friends
said
he wanted to start a family with his
wife he could not wait to be a father
now this is interesting because we do
come to find out that scott no longer
had interest in his wife
he started to cheat on lacey several
months ago and he would even tell his
mistress amber that he did not want to
have any kids
lacey's mom sharon rocca said that lacey
had once told her that scott would not
feel her belly while she was pregnant
i happen to think this was scott's way
of staying disconnected from the
situation
he did not want any children so by not
feeling his wife's belly and feeling the
baby kick
he could continue living his life as if
this wasn't really happening
because he was hoping to find a way out
of being a father
obviously this is my speculation now the
first major lead that doesn't point at
scott comes up about six days later on
december 30th
this is when everyone finds out about a
burglary that happened directly across
the street from scott and lacey's house
there was a witness that lives near
scott and lacey who was driving by their
house on the morning of december 24th
the same day lacey went missing around
11 40 am that morning
the witness said they saw some
suspicious looking people standing
outside of a white van
the witness doesn't realize it till
later but when she finds out the
medina's house was broken into
most likely on the same day of the 24th
she later puts two and two together
realizing it would have been on the same
day that lacey went missing
at first lacy's brother wanted to focus
on the burglary because it did seem like
one hell of a coincidence
this was looking like a good lead but
the investigators come out and say the
burglary actually happened on the 26th
that would have been days after lacey
was already missing
this did not seem very likely though
because how could the burglars have
broken into that house when their street
already had cop cars and news vehicles
on the block
reporting on lacy's disappearance did
the investigators really try to bury
this lead because they were so focused
on scott
there was a news anchor that said there
is no way that burglary happened on a 26
because he was standing outside the
petersen home that morning
and he did not see anything out of the
ordinary he said he would have seen a
suspicious
van or suspicious characters leaving the
house directly across the street
we find out later that the witness was
right the robbery happened on the
morning of christmas eve
the same morning lacey went missing so
maybe
just maybe lacey was outside walking the
dog
as this was happening maybe lacey tried
to stop these men from robbing her
neighbor's house
and things went horribly wrong maybe
they abducted lacie because she was a
witness
honestly who knows when this case does
eventually go to trial
the jury does not hear any of this now
what's very interesting is when one of
the burglars scott todd
was interviewed by the detectives about
the burglary the first words out of his
mouth were
i had nothing to do with the missing
pregnant girl but for some reason
the investigators did not want to talk
to him about lacy's disappearance
they already had their eyes fixated on
scott peterson
several weeks before the trial was over
there was an inmate at the jail
who reaches out to one of the
investigators working for scott's
defense team
he said that he had information about
the burglary across the street from the
peterson home
this inmate at the jail did give scott's
lawyers a name
shawn tenbrink and when they search his
name in the database
they find out one of the watch
commanders at the jail had been trying
to contact the police about this inmate
apparently this inmate who was at the
jail had a phone conversation with his
brother
who was a very close friend to scott
todd the man who robbed the house across
the street from the petersens
during this conversation he said that
scott todd told him
lacey did confront them during the
burglary and he
threatened lacey when lacy's name came
up during the conversation
sean told his brother to shut up several
times he knew the conversation was
monitored since they were in jail
now the watch commander who was working
that night knew this was significant
so he recorded the conversation and he
did send it to the modesto police
he called this in back in january only a
few weeks after lacey went missing
long before the trial was ever started
he called this in several
times before they would even call him
back he said he gave a copy of the
recording to the investigators but they
said they don't have one
it sounds like they wanted this to be
buried they had no
interest in exploring other options now
let me get back to scott peterson
let me show you where things started to
go sideways for scott and lacey
i believe this all started when scott
met another woman
named amber frye one thing that i always
found
interesting was the fact that scott even
began dating amber
when she already had a child during one
of their phone conversations scott tells
amber that he doesn't want to have any
kids
i think it's interesting because i would
assume that most of the public thinks
that scott killed lacie because he did
not want to become a father
yet he goes after another woman who
already had a child
scott's relationship with amber frye
begins five weeks before lacey goes
missing
amber's friend shawn told her about this
guy that she had met at a work
convention
amber's friend said scott is perfect for
you
so she agrees to meet him and they do
begin dating
while lacey's at home getting ready to
bring their first child into this world
scott is out having fun with his new
girlfriend at first
amber felt like their relationship was
great that was until scott admitted that
he had lied to her
he said there was something that he
needed to tell her scott revealed that
he had been married but he said
he lost his wife he said this would be
the first holiday season without her
for a while amber believes him and even
feels sorry for him
she doesn't begin to find out what's
really happening until a couple days
later after christmas when her friend
hands her the newspaper
which had scott and lacy's photo all
over it this is when amber realizes
scott's wife had recently gone missing
after he had already said she was dead
when the investigators get into contact
with amber
she agreed to help them in their
investigation they end up going to radio
shack to get a device to use on our
phone
so they could record our conversations
with scott like always
he lies during the conversations saying
he's over in france
while he's actually in modesto looking
for his missing wife an unborn child
scott actually calls her during lacey's
candlelight vigil
on new year's eve saying that he's
standing under the eiffel tower
i mean what a scumbag amber does
eventually confront scott
because he said his wife was dead and
this would be the first holidays without
her
you see scott said this around december
9th
several weeks before his wife actually
went missing this is also allegedly the
same exact day he bought his boat
the day scott tells his new girlfriend
that his wife is dead
was the same day he goes out and buys a
boat i wonder what his intentions were
now how would he have predicted his
wife's death weeks before it happened
unless he knew it would happen or can he
guess the future
this shows scott has been lying to
everyone
when scott later sits down for an
interview he lies right to everyone on
national tv
when he says he revealed his
relationship with amber to the police
he says that he told them from day one
but during his interrogation
you can see that he never mentions it he
actually said everything was fine
between him and his wife
he also said that he told his wife about
amber before she went missing
but of course lacey isn't there to
confirm this so he can say whatever the
hell he wants
when amber fry comes out as scott's
secret lover
lacy's family instantly turns on him
they begin to question what else he
might be hiding
this is when the volunteer center is
shut down immediately
they felt betrayed by scott and
rightfully so
shortly after all of this is when there
is another major development
in the case the bodies of lacey and her
son connor
are found washed up on the shore of the
san francisco bay
baby connor is actually found first then
about 18 hours later
they found a torso that washed up in the
bay at first
they weren't even exactly sure if it was
a man or a woman
that was until the dna results came back
confirming it was lacey
and her son lacey's hands feet
and her head were missing from the body
this is when scott goes from suspect
number one
to a wanted man all of the investigators
now firmly believe
scott peterson dumped his wife's body in
the bay when he went fishing there on
christmas eve
the same day she went missing the only
thing is
no one has seen scott at his house
lately his neighbors hadn't seen him in
weeks
scott was actually hiding out down in
san diego with his family
on the same day that the bodies were
found the cops wanted to arrest scott
they had been following him around all
day while scott was weaving in and out
of traffic
according to scott he said that he
thought he was being followed by the
news media
because scott was driving so erratically
the cops ultimately decided to take him
into custody at that time
although the dna results were still not
back in from the lab
when they end up searching his car this
is when things get interesting
inside of his car they find camping gear
nearly fifteen thousand dollars in cash
his brother's identification and four
different cell phones
they believe scott had been living out
of his car and scott also looked
slightly different
he now had a beard and all of his hair
was dyed
it seemed as if scott was about to make
a run for the border
but as always scott had an excuse for
everything found in his vehicle
when the investigators informed him that
the bodies found in the bay were in fact
his missing wife and son
he had no reaction it's almost as if
scott knew
this day was coming but you know what
they say everyone handles grief in their
own way
shortly after scott is arrested he has
his first hearing where he pleads not
guilty
this is when scott's family hires mark
gregeros as his lawyer for about 1
million dollars
he was a high profile lawyer who is used
to being in the spotlight because he's
handled other cases that were in the
public eye
when the case does eventually go to
trial the investigator's theory is scott
killed lacie on the night of december
23rd
he then made his anchors to attach the
each one of her limbs
including around her neck then he loaded
her up in the boat
took her to the marina and dumped her
body in the bay
now what's interesting is there was a
witness at the marina that day
this witness said they saw scott
launching his boat into the water
and the boat did appear to be empty
inside for some reason
scott's lawyer never had the witness
testify for him
during the opening statements of the
trial scott's attorney delivers a blow
to the prosecution's theory
they had claimed that scott lied about
what he did the morning lacey went
missing
they said he had lied about watching
martha stewart with his wife
but scott's lawyer did show a recording
of that episode in front of the jury
scott was exactly right about what
martha was making on her show that day
another thing that worked in scott's
favor was what the computer analyst
discovered
he learned that someone from the
petersen home was on the computer the
morning
lacey went missing looking up umbrellas
that had sunflowers on them
lacey was known to love sunflowers so
they assumed that it was her looking it
up
so the question is if lacey was murdered
on the night of the 23rd
as they suspect then how was she looking
up umbrellas and watching martha stewart
on the morning of the 24th since there
were no witnesses to the murder
and no physical evidence showing scott
did this to his wife an unborn child
the state did not have much to go with
one of the main things that ended up
being a major turning point for the
prosecution were the recordings of scott
and amber's phone calls
up until then the prosecution had a very
weak case
now the jury was finally able to hear
scott lying about certain details to
amber
when the jury hears this this is when
they question everything else he's ever
said
then they test the boat to see if scott
could have possibly thrown lacy
out of the boat without sinking it they
actually brought in an expert fisherman
who knows how to handle large fish
roughly the way to lacey
who was about 150 pounds at the time
they did this test several different
times and the boat flipped over
every time getting the man inside
soaking wet
scott's lawyer said this made him look
innocent because scott could not have
successfully done this
however when scott got home the day from
the marina
we know that he was soaking wet because
the first thing he told the cops was
when he got home
he threw his soaking wet clothes in the
washer then he got in the shower
now i have seen other videos say that
the boat that was used during the test
was not the same one that scott had
but that's not accurate they
specifically said it was the same boat
by the same manufacturing company and
they had even done that test
at the identical time of the year in the
bay the judge would not allow this
expert to be added into the evidence
though because he said it was not
similar enough to the state's theory of
what happened the day scott would have
done this
one of the other things the defense
attorney shot down was the evidence
discovered by the cadaver dogs
apparently the dogs were able to find
lacey's sent at the marina where scott
had allegedly taken her body
but they find out almost immediately
that these dogs failed to earn their
certifications
therefore the dogs were not very
reliable one of the other things that
happened was
there was a doctor that stated baby
conor was still alive
up until december 29th based on his
findings
this would have meant scott could not
have thrown lacey in the bay on the 24th
which is what the prosecutors claimed if
this were accurate
lacey and her baby would have still been
alive five days after scott reported her
missing
if this was right then that would almost
have to mean that someone else abducted
lacey because scott's house and
warehouse had already been
searched by the cops and all the news
outlets had already descended onto those
locations
we know lacey obviously wasn't being
held there captive
so if she was still alive up until
december 29th
that means she would have been held
captive somewhere else
this doctor's credibility was put into
question during the cross-examination
and this is when that theory began to
fall apart
there were several different things the
doctor could not explain
and he got to the point of frustration
when he said give me some slack
everything this doctor said was now
irrelevant
the jury no longer took the doctor
serious after that
however there was another doctor who
said baby connor may have been alive
up until january 3rd based on a
scientific formula
that determines how old a baby is at the
time of their death
based upon the size of their bones if
this was accurate
conor would have died well after scott
was under investigation
how could he have got rid of the bodies
in the bay when his boat was already
seized into evidence
now let's get into the witnesses who say
they saw laci walking the dog that day
sometime between 9 50 and 10 am
witnesses say they saw a woman who
appeared to be very pregnant
walking a dog the day lacey went missing
another witness says she saw someone
fitting lacy's description walking a dog
in the park
while men were following her shortly
after the witness say they saw this
the men began to yell at this woman
telling her to shut the dog
up the investigator stated that no one
came forward about seeing lacie walking
the dog
but one witness says he told this to a
motorcycle cop
so we really don't know who's lying if
the witnesses are right
and they did see lacey how did scott
have lacy with him as he made his way to
the bay to dump her body
something doesn't add up here another
big part of the case is witnesses seeing
lacy walk the dog
after scott left that day witnesses said
they saw lacey walking the dog around
the neighborhood
and in the local park around 10 30 to 10
45
am that day however we know that
peterson's neighbor karen service
actually found their dog loose in the
yard around 10 18
am this neighbor secured the dog in the
backyard then left
so how did the witnesses see lacey
walking the dog at this time
when the dog was already in the backyard
after the neighbor had left it there
either these witnesses saw someone else
or the time they think they saw lacy was
way off
so as you can see there was a good
amount of evidence that was in scott's
favor but there was also a good amount
of evidence that shows scott did this
himself
now i want to discuss what happened
during the deliberations because this is
when things turn into a disaster
for those of you that don't know or
simply don't remember
this scott and lacey peterson case
became a national story almost
immediately
from the day that lacey went missing up
until the verdict was read
this story made headlines almost every
single day
it became a media circus i think most of
america thought scott was guilty
long before he ever had his day in court
the public opinion on this case could
not be avoided
and i think most of us had our minds
made up well before all the evidence was
known
when this happens it's very hard for
someone to get a fair trial
even if the suspect is guilty and
everyone knows it it still has to be
proven in a court of law
i'm not confident that happened in this
case now
during the first day of deliberations
the jury voted on whether they thought
he was guilty or innocent
the votes came out 10 to 2 in favor of
scott being guilty
but the foremen of the jury voted
innocent i find this to be interesting
because the foreman was arguably the
smartest man in the room
he is basically the captain of the jury
this foreman was not only a doctor
but he was also a lawyer even some of
the other jurors said
this foreman was taking notes on every
single detail
so it almost sounds as if he wanted to
be fair instead of basing his opinion
off emotion
this is what you want and this is what
you need in a juror
especially on a case that involves a
double homicide now on day five of the
deliberations
one of the jurors decided to look up
something on the internet about the case
and this led to her being removed from
the jury
now a new juror had to be brought in for
the deliberations but they had to start
them
all over again this new member of the
jury
rochelle comes in and immediately says
scott is guilty
i mean as soon as she walked in she did
not want to discuss it with anyone else
she did not want to go through the
evidence logically she already had it in
her mind that scott was guilty
now keep in mind this new juror rochelle
is the reason
scott's death penalty was recently
reversed like i said before
i fully believe scott is guilty but this
is not how things are done
the original foreman of the jury did not
want to allow this to happen
he more or less said she cannot come in
here and dictate the entire room
at this time the foreman of the jury was
still thinking about voting scott
not guilty well all the other jurors
found a way to get the foreman
off of the jury they were very impatient
they did not want to waste any more time
looking at the evidence logically
so for the second time in two days
another juror was dismissed
it would have actually been a hung jury
if not for the foreman leaving the trial
once that happened everything changed
now the new juror rochelle
had control over the entire room scott
would now be found guilty
and sentenced to death this happened in
less than 24 hours
after rochelle was brought into the
deliberations room
it was later discovered that rochelle
had been involved in her own
kind of domestic dispute that left her
in fear for her own unborn child
so you can see why she would have such
an emotional investment in a case that
involves the death of an unborn child
she should never have been allowed on
this case but since she lied about it
she was able to slip by now at the end
of the day
i think scott is exactly where he
belongs and i want to tell you some of
the reasons why i believe scott is
guilty
there is one thing scott did that i can
never get over
no matter how much evidence makes me
think he did not do it
there is always one thing that i always
go back to that lets me know
he's guilty i'm referring to when scott
told his new girlfriend amber
that this would be the first holiday
without his wife this lets me know
exactly what scott wanted
he wanted his wife gone he said this to
amber on december 9th
but lacey did not vanish until christmas
eve
amber even recorded their phone
conversation where scott admits that he
said this before
lacey went missing scott was basically
chris watts before chris watts was chris
watts
if you know what i mean scott found a
new girlfriend
and soon realized he no longer wanted to
be a father
he wanted this new life instead but in
order to have the new life
he would have to get rid of the old one
and that started by
scott telling amber that his wife was
already gone because he knew one day she
really would be gone
that's why he bought that boat within
hours of saying that
he knew he would have to make her
disappear now one thing i haven't
mentioned
yet is what happened when the
investigators looked into the hard
drives on scott's computer
when the computer expert analyzed his
five hard drives
there was some very interesting
revelations on the same exact day scott
went online to buy his new boat
he also started researching the water
currents in the san francisco bay
they found out that scott was looking at
different maps of the bay
as well as fishing reports and a u.s
geological survey chart of the water
currents
i think scott was looking this up so he
could make sure lacy's body would drift
out to the sea
after he dumped it in the bay think
about what scott said when he was
interviewed by the investigators on the
day lacey went missing
he said he wanted to go golfing that
morning but it was way too cold
so he went fishing instead i don't know
about you
but fishing on the bay would have been a
hell of a lot colder than golfing on the
land
i've been to the san francisco bay and i
was even there in the springtime
and let me tell you something it was
freezing out on the bay when i was there
i can only imagine what it must have
felt like in december
besides who goes fishing on christmas
eve of all days
when you have a pregnant wife at home
who is due almost any day
one of the other things that really
disgusted me about scott was the fact
that he got rid of lacy's land rover
shortly after she went missing that's
right only weeks after lacey went
missing
scott wanted to get himself a new truck
so he traded in lacey's only car
so he could get it you know why because
scott knew she wasn't coming back home
in scott's mind there was no reason to
have lacy's things around the house
anymore
because he knew she wasn't coming back
he actually had the nerve to do this
even while he was under the microscope
of the investigators and the news
reporters
that just shows you his character now
you know what makes this even sadder
the man who owned that car lot the one
that scott went to to trade in lacey's
land rover
he actually gave that back to lacey's
family himself
even though the owner of the car lot
would be losing money on this
he did not want the land rover for
himself he said
he wanted to give the car back to
lacey's family because he wanted lacie
to have a car for when she came back
home
so he gave it to lacey's mom and dad
almost one year before lacey went
missing
scott took out life insurance of nearly
250
000 on his wife even after he was
convicted
he fought to get that money he did not
want lacey's mom and dad to have it
again this is only another example of
his character
in my mind scott did this he wanted a
new life with his new girlfriend but for
some
reason he felt like the best way to do
this was to murder his wife and unborn
son
i will never understand why some men
think this is the better option
get a divorce fellas yeah it might be a
headache
and it might even be expensive but
what's worse
losing half of everything or losing
everything
if you no longer want to be in a
relationship with someone then leave
them
don't be a monster who kills your entire
family then discards them like they're
trash
believe me this won't make life any
easier for you
but what do i know do you think scott is
guilty
or innocent leave me your thoughts down
below i want to thank everyone for
watching my first official true crime
video
this was a lot of fun to make and
hopefully if enough of you like the
video
then i will make more like this either
way have a great day everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
you